>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> R. J. Palacio: I will say
that if you've read my book,
you know that it's about a
10-year-old boy named Auggie Pullman
who was born with a very
severe craniofacial difference,
which makes him the subject of
many stares, and social cruelties,
and an easy target for bullies.
He's singled out because
of what he looks like.
But, despite the unkindnesses
that have been hurled
at him his whole life, Auggie
himself is incapable, or unwilling,
to resort to unkindness himself.
Instead he greets the
world with the courage
of his own inherent kindness.
He fights cruelty with humor.
He meets ignorance with grace.
The reason he's a wonder isn't
because of the 27 surgeries,
or because he looks so different.
He's a wonder because despite
every reason to distrust the world,
he marches into it with a
brave heart, and a ready,
if not easy-to-fathom smile.
That's why readers around the world
have taken Auggie into their hearts.
He reminds them that kindness
is what makes people great.
If Auggie Pullman can be kind
despite everything he's been
through, if he can
find that kindness
within him, so can everybody.
Let's see, what else I
can say from this speech.
I will also just add, since
I'm here in Washington.
I am the daughter of immigrants.
I'm a first-generation American.
My parents didn't know any
English when they came here.
My first language, my
mother tongue, was Spanish.
I'm completely bi-lingual.
And, I'm the product of
a public-school education
in a blue-collar neighborhood
in Flushing, Queens.
In fact, where my best
friend growing up,
Meg Medina [assumed spelling],
is in the audience, too.
She grew up there as well.
[ Applause ]
I will also add, I grew
up a 15-minute drive away
from where Donald Trump grew up,
but we had very different
childhoods and upbringings.
I was taught by my immigrant
parents to value art and literature.
I was taught by my father to
marvel at the wonders of science.
I was taught by my
mother to revere books.
I was taught by my teachers
to value the ideas of others,
even if they were different
from mine.
You know, that saying, I may
not agree with what you say,
but I will fight to the
death your right to say it.
That is at the heart
of American values.
I was taught by my neighbors,
even those who weren't thrilled
at having Latinos in their
neighborhood, that class has nothing
to do with income, and
everything to do with outcome.
[ Applause ]
I'm telling you these things
just to explain what it feels
like to hear our president announce
legislation that would bar people
like my parents to immigrate
here legally, to this country,
because they don't know English.
Please understand the outrage I feel
when I see white supremacists decry
my right to live here and be here.
Please understand my dismay
at leaders and pundits
who don't denounce
Nazis and the KKK.
Please understand my
disappointment in the people
who say they love my book's message,
but nevertheless defend policies
that hurt real-life Auggies.
It's incompatible.
I will tell you a little-- just
a very, very small anecdote
about a family that I've become
really, really good friends with.
They have a son who has
Treacher Collins syndrome,
and when I met this boy,
it's like, I thought,
oh my goodness, this is like Auggie.
A real-life Auggie.
He looked exactly the way I
imagined Auggie looks like.
And, during the healthcare
debates of last month,
I got this text from the dad.
And, he's like, I've been crying
all night, because if this happens,
you know, Nathaniel
[assumed spelling] will--
he's like, tapped out, he's
maxed out of his life-time cap.
I mean, I don't know
what we're going to do.
There're real life Auggies.
There are kids who are born
with physical ailments who need,
and need us to fight for them,
and so, how do we do that?
Do we march?
Do we protest?
Do we write?
And, the answer is
yes, yes, and yes.
But, more than anything we vote.
We have to choose kind, we have
to vote kind, and I'm not talking
about voting in national
elections only.
I'm talking about voting
in local elections.
Voting for school board
people who believe in science.
I'm talking about voting
for Congressional people,
state legislators, who, you
know, who advocate and will fight
for the things that you
want and believe in.
Because the state government affects
national government much more
than we know.
So, with that, I will end and
will say that I'm so sorry
that I've turned this into
sort of, a sermon on kindness.
But, I just feel like if you
give me, you know, a pen to write
about something, I
write about kindness.
And, if you give me a soapbox
to talk about something,
I'm going to talk about kindness.
So, right now, we have 10 minutes.
I'm happy to answer
any questions you want.
I'm happy to change the subject,
and talk about anything you want.
Are there-- oh, there we go.
Hi there.
>> Where did you get the inspiration
for the character Summer?
>> R. J. Palacio: Summer.
That's such a-- because
everyone loves Summer.
Summer's one of my
favorite characters.
And you know, I would say first,
that almost all the characters
in Wonder, are based, kind of, on
like, mashups of people I know.
So, Auggie himself is kind of, a
mashup between my son when he was
that age, and his best
friend, and Jack Will,
for instance is also a mashup
of two boys, two brothers,
one was named Jack, the
other was named Will.
Summer is the only one
that is actually based
on a real little girl I
knew who was named Summer,
who was the nicest
little girl I'd ever met.
She was so sweet and kind, and
I used to say to her mother,
it's like, oh my God,
she's so amazing.
And, the mother would say, I know,
it's, you know, it's you know,
sometimes, you know, we
have kids, and they're like,
better than anything
we've ever, like,
been able to do, you know, raise.
And, this little girl, Summer,
was truly a remarkable young lady.
Next. Yes.
>> Hi. First off, I want to say
thank you so much for your writing.
>> R. J. Palacio: Oh, thank you.
>> I teach fifth grade and
we read your book every year,
and it's opened up so many
conversations about empathy
and compassion in our
classrooms, so thank you so much.
>> R. J. Palacio: Thank you so much.
>> I wanted to ask
you, what are some
of the most inspiring actions
you've seen children take
after reading Wonder?
>> R. J. Palacio: You know,
I think for me, personally,
one of the best things about writing
Wonder is hearing stories like that,
and just hearing-- getting so many
emails, unfortunately too many
to respond to, of things
that kids have been inspired
to do after reading Wonder.
I almost can't think, you know,
everything from raising money
at lemonade stands for Operation
Smile, to visiting hospitals
that specialize in facial
reconstruction for young kids.
My favorite though, came very, very
soon after Wonder was published.
Where, let's see how quickly
I can tell this story.
There was a little boy whose
mother was the president
of the Children's Craniofacial
Foundation, and she has a blog.
And, her little son,
Peter [assumed spelling],
was a big fan of Wonder early on,
and he wrote a little guest
blog post for his mom,
talking about all the ways
he was like Auggie Pullman.
Like Auggie Pullman, he
had a facial difference.
Like Auggie Pullman,
he needed hearing aids.
Like Auggie Pullman, he
had an October birthday,
like Auggie Pullman,
he loved Star Wars.
But, then he said,
unlike Auggie Pullman,
I've never had a standing ovation.
Somewhere across the country,
there was a class of fifth-graders
who were reading Wonder, and I guess
they came across this blog post.
And then, they sent him, Peter,
this little boy they'd never met,
a video of themselves
saying, you know, Peter,
we heard that you like Wonder.
We like Wonder too,
and this is for you.
And then, they filmed themselves
giving him a standing ovation.
That was when-- I mean, I remember
opening that email, showing--
I was still working in my
office, and we all were,
like, crying at that email.
So, I think that was
one of my favorites.
There have been so many,
though, so it's been great.
Yes?
>> Did you get to meet Daveed Diggs?
>> R. J. Palacio: I did!
It was so cool, and even more,
my kids got to meet him too,
and they're huge Hamilton fans,
and that was-- and it's so funny,
let me just say to all the
grownups in the room, I mean,
I was floored when
I met Julia Roberts.
For my kids, it was
all about Daveed Diggs.
And, also Mandy Patinkin,
Inigo Montoya, you know?
That was big.
So, yes.
>> What does your--
>> R. J. Palacio: Oh, sorry,
I think you're next, yes.
>> OK. So first, I
just want to thank you
for kind of, an obscure reason.
I first read Wonder when I
was 11, and when I saw, like,
the random little part about
Via reading War and Peace
when she was 15, that
kind of inspired me.
And, I just finished
it, like, a month ago,
and it's the best thing
I've ever read,
so thank you very much for that.
>> R. J. Palacio: Thank you!
Thank you, I am so
thrilled to hear it.
Isn't it the best thing, ever?
I read it when I was your age.
People say, oh, is a 15-year-old
going to read War and Peace?
I did. And, it is so good.
It is not hard, it's
like soap opera stuff.
I mean, it's really--
well, better than that.
But, it's really, really,
good, right?
I'm so glad you enjoyed it.
>> Yes.
>> What's your favorite of Mr.
Brown's precepts from the book?
>> R. J. Palacio: You know, I
think-- my favorite precept.
Well, I guess, if you have
the choice between being right
and being kind, choose kind.
I would say that that
is probably my favorite.
I will also say, it's not
in the original precepts,
but it is one of Mr. Brown's
precepts in one of my other books,
another precept I really love is,
be kind because everyone you
meet is fighting a hard battle.
And, I like that because it reminds
us that everyone's got a story
to tell and sometimes we just
have to take the time to listen,
you know, and be compassionate.
So, thank you.
Yes.
>> I'm a parent volunteer
in a classroom,
and I first read Auggie to--
as a reading group volunteer
at Glenwood Elementary School
in San Rafael to the
third-graders, and of course,
Auggie and all the children
touched me beyond belief.
And, I'm crying just
thinking about them.
But, while we were reading the book,
I kept wondering where's the
adult outside of the family?
Where's the adult?
Come on, somebody's got
to jump in and help.
And, then Mr. Tushman
came into the picture.
So, my comment slash
question is twofold.
What can we do as adults to
be more like the Mr. Tushman?
How can we get more Mr.
Tushmans into our schools?
There are so many schools
that don't have that presence
and the adult role models.
And then, would you ever
do a Mr. Tushman chapter,
or have we had enough of him?
I don't know.
>> R. J. Palacio: Well,
those are great questions.
I think-- I love Mr. Tushman.
I, you know, it was very important
for me when I wrote Wonder
to make sure that the grownups
in the book were decent,
nice, good people.
Because I had noticed a tendency in
some of the middle grade fiction,
and also like, on TV
shows and stuff,
to make grownups rather, unhelpful.
Let's put it that way.
And so, you know, Mr. Tushman,
to me-- I have five minutes,
so I'm just going to try
to do it really quick.
I would say, before,
what I said about voting
and local school boards, one of
the reasons that's so important is
because I think a lot
of teachers would
like to be more like Mr. Tushman.
And, I feel like they are
not always allowed to.
They spend a lot of time
fighting political battles
that they shouldn't be.
They should be, it should be a
humanist approach to education
and I do think that if we work
a little bit more about sort of,
changing the school boards, and
the people that are, kind of,
representing interests
that really aren't
in their children's best
interest, in terms of, again,
separation of church and
state, and all that stuff.
I think that there would be
more Mr. Tushmans who rise,
and who will be able to meet
the needs of these children.
I think all adults should
remember that, I mean,
we're not just parenting
our own kids.
We have to look out for
other people's kids, too.
You know, it's not enough
to be content, you know,
when you have a kid in
the fifth or sixth grade,
and to know that socially,
oh my kid's doing great,
I don't have to worry about them.
Or, my kid's popular and
everything, you know.
Keep an eye out for those kids that
are struggling at the lower end
of those social hierarchy ladders.
Because they need help too.
And, sometimes it's other parents,
teachers, other people who, kind of,
step in and help those children.
So, I think, you know, not to,
again, not to quote a great woman.
But, it takes a village, and you
know, we should all remember that.
So, I only have time
for one last question.
I think, or maybe two, depends.
Two minutes, so let's go with you.
Yes.
>> When Jack punched
Julian in the face,
was it really for Auggie,
or was it just for Jack?
>> R. J. Palacio: That's
a great question.
What do you think?
>> For Jack.
>> R. J. Palacio: You know, one
of the great things about writing,
is that I have my opinion, but the
great thing is that you, sort of,
you know-- writing and reading
a book, they're the two sides
of the same thing, so if that's
your opinion, then, it's right.
I would say the same thing.
Having said that, when my younger
son read Wonder for the first time,
he asked me a question like, I think
it was a question like, which--
who was the other boy in the mummy
mask during the Halloween thing.
Was it Miles or Henry?
And, I said, well, which do you
want it to be, and he said, no,
that's not a good answer.
Is it Miles or Henry.
Like, so having said that, I would
say that your answer is right,
but I think it was also
for Auggie a little bit.
I think he felt, I think that Jack
just felt really bad in general
about everything that was going on.
He felt guilty, he felt shame,
and in a way, Julian just,
he just kind of, like, said the
wrong thing at the wrong time,
and Jack just had a moment.
Like, he shouldn't have hit Julian.
We should never resort to hitting.
But, I think he was just
at his breaking point.
And, that's why he did it.
So, it was a little bit for
himself, a little bit for Auggie.
I think you're right.
So, I am told I have
to wrap it up now.
Thank you so much.
You've been such a great
crowd, and I really--
I so, I'm so happy to have been
able to talk to you, and so grateful
for your time, so thank you
very much, and take care.
Goodbye.